Thanks Bjorn n done.
I've really been looking forward to coming today.
I actually grew up just a stone's throw away in Stuyvesant town and my dad owned
a toy store right across the street from there.
So it's always fun to come home.
But also because a lot of my work recently in the last decade or so has been on
the history of science and I actually use Google tools all the time when I'm
doing that work and they're extraordinarily helpful.
So it,
so it's a pleasure to have a chance to talk with you today.
So I'm going to start with a question.
I suppose that you could build the perfect dog.
What would be the key ingredients in your recipe?
Well,
you definitely want cute,
maybe something with floppy ears and a curly tail that wags and anticipation
whenever you're around,
you'd want smart,
you'd want loyal,
and you definitely want unconditional love.
The thing is that you do not need to build this animal because for the last 60
years,
a dedicated team of Russian geneticists in Siberia have been building it for
you.
The perfect dog,
except as you might guess from the title of today's talk,
it's not a dog at all.
It's a Fox,
a domesticated Fox.
They built this in the minus 40 degree winters of Siberia,
but more importantly,
they built it in the blink of an eye in terms of evolutionary time,
a hundredth of the time that I took our ancestors to domesticate wolves into
dogs.
This is my friend and colleague and coauthor,
Lewd Mila
would.
Mila recently turned 85 years old and every day,
including today for the last 60 years,
she has led what's come to be known as the Silver Fox domestication experiment.
And for the last 10 years or so,
I've had the honor of working with her as a historian of science to tell the
story of what they have done to as many people as we possibly can.
So today I am going to tell you about domesticated foxes that will melt your
hearts and lick your ears just like this guy did.
Five seconds after they put them into my arms in Siberia.
More than that though.
I'm going to tell you about cutting edge work on this process of domestication,
which is not something only of interest to biologists because if you think about
it,
when our ancestors began domesticating plants and animals,
we dramatically changed our own evolutionary history.
We would be very,
very different if we had not done that.
And this experiment that we're going to talk about is the gold standard for
understanding how domestication comes about.
So I'm going to try and give you an overview of what they've been doing and why
it's important.
60 years.
The experiment starts with this fellow Dimitri Goliath.
In the late 1930s Goliath was an undergraduate student at a place called the Eva
Nova Agricultural Academy outside of Moscow.
And while he was there,
he studied genetics and because it was an agricultural academy,
he had all sorts of interactions with domesticated species when he graduated,
even Nova,
like every Soviet male of that era,
he went and fought in World War II for four years.
After that,
he came back and landed a position as a research scientist at a place called the
central research laboratory.
For for breeding animals also in Moscow and it was there that belie of came up
with the idea that would eventually become this silver Fox domestication
experiment.
And it started like this.
He knew from his interaction with domesticated species and also from reading
Darwin's famous book about domestication.
He knew that many domesticated animals share a house suite of characteristics,
so they tend to have things like floppy ears and curly tails.
They also tend to have sort of juvenile lies,
body and facial features compared to their wild ancestors.
They tend to have low stress hormone levels.
They tend to have all sorts of variation in their coat color,
and they also typically have much longer reproductive seasons.
Then their wild ancestors,
not every domesticated animal has every one of those characteristics,
but most have many of those characteristics.
So much so that that whole thing,
the floppy ears,
the curly tail tails,
the low stress on moments,
all that is referred to today as the domestication syndrome
and belay have thought about this and he thought,
you know,
this is really weird because our ancestors domesticated species for all sorts of
different reasons.
Sunlight,
horses.
We domesticated for transportation.
Others we domesticated as food sources and yet others like dogs.
We domesticated for some combination of protection and companionship.
Yet regardless of what we domesticate them for,
they tend to have many of the characteristics in the domestication syndrome.
Why
and the layoffs hypothesis went like this.
The one thing that our ancestors always needed in whatever species they were
trying to domesticate was an animal that would not try and bite their heads off.
And so he hypothesized that the earliest stages of all animal domestication
events involved our ancestors choosing the calmest,
tamest friendliest towards human animals.
He further hypothesize that somehow,
and he really didn't know how,
but somehow all of those other characteristics and the domestication syndrome,
longer reproductive periods,
juvenile eyes,
facial features,
all of that with somehow genetically connected to choosing animals based on how
friendly they were towards humans,
and he decided he would test these ideas in real time using the foxes that he
became very familiar with at the laboratory for,
for breeding animals.
Because at that laboratory,
the two key species they worked with were foxes and mink because there was so
much money associated with Fox for and mink fur,
so he decided he would test these ideas in foxes and the experiment he envision
was very basic.
At its core,
he imagined testing hundreds of foxes and choosing the calmest ones,
the ones that are most friendly towards humans preferentially breeding them.
Then when they're pups grow up,
test them,
preferentially choose the ones that are friendliest towards humans do this
generation after generation after generation foxes breed once a year,
so essentially one year equals one generation.
He would do this every generation and he would see first of all was he in fact
getting inherently calmer,
friendlier to human animals and it's strictly choosing them based on how
friendly they were.
Did he also begin to see the emergence of other traits in the domestication
syndrome?
Right?
Did they start showing lower stress hormone or hormone levels or other
characteristics of domestication syndrome?
This is a classic experiment in evolution and genetics.
But belay have had a problem and it was a big problem because as he came up with
this idea in mid 1940s it was a time when he was illegal to do modern genetics
in the Soviet Union.
And the reason that it was illegal was because of this person right here.
Trophism Lysenko Lysenko was a fraud.
A Charlatan is pseudo scientists who had risen up both in the scientific and
political ranks of the Soviet Union.
And what Lysenko said was that modern genetics was Bougie.
Are Science being promulgated by wreckers and spies from the West?
That instead he argued a long disproven idea known as Lamarckian inheritance was
in fact not only correct,
but more in line with Soviet philosophy.
He then went and made up a bunch of studies that he never did to suggest that he
was in fact,
right.
And by doing this,
he rose up to become not only one of the most powerful scientists in the Soviet
Union,
but Stalin's right hand man on science.
So this picture comes from a conference where Lysenko was giving one of these
fire spinning talks,
calling Western geneticists saboteurs and wreckers.
And when he finish,
Stalin's stood up and yelled out,
Bravo Comrade Lysenko because of Lysenko,
thousands of Soviet geneticists lost their jobs.
Hundreds,
we're thrown into prison.
And about 20 were actually murdered by Lysenko Sankoh's thugs for doing the
crime of modern western genetics.
This is the environment in which belay of is conceiving an experiment in
genetics.
Nobody knows better how dangerous this is because one of those 20 people who was
murdered by Lysenko was ballet [inaudible] older brother,
20 years older,
who had been an up and coming star in the field of genetics,
but lay of decided this was too important and he was going to do it.
So he initiated a tiny little pilot study.
He has a friend who runs a Fox farm in Estonia and there are hundreds of these
Fox farms around the Soviet Union and their satellites because again,
there's so much money selling Fox firs to the west.
So he talks to one of his colleagues in Estonia who runs one of these smaller
farms and he says,
here's what I want to do.
I want to even experiment where I select the calmest Hamus ones.
And it's a small pilot experiment,
involves testing a couple of dozen foxes every year,
test them on how friendly or not they are towards humans.
Breathe the ones that are friendliest and he and his colleagues do this for four
or five years and the results are promising.
Even in that short amount of time,
they began to see animals that were inherently a little friendlier towards
humans,
then believes,
get belief gets his big chance to start a full blown experiment in 1958 what
happens is he is offered a position as vice director at a new institute of
biology in Siberia in a place called Novosibirsk.
And this institute is part of a place that still exists today called Academic
Gora doc or the academic village.
Basically what happened was in the mid to late 1950s,
the Soviet Soviet,
uh,
political leaders and scientists work together and what they did was they
cleared out a large chunk of Siberian forest near Novosibirsk and they built two
dozen worldclass institutes associated with science.
So there was the institute that [inaudible] was involved in as vice director in
biology.
There was,
there were institutes in chemistry,
physics,
early computer science and so on and so on.
They literally brought in tens of thousands of scientists and associated people
to build this academic village.
So ballet if knows now that as vice director of this new institute of biology
there that he's going to have the power and the money to start a full blown
silver Fox domestication experiment.
But because of all the administrative stuff he's going to have to do as vice
director,
what he's not going to have is the time to be the person to lead the experiment
on a day to day basis.
So right before he moves to academic or dock,
while he's still in Moscow,
he goes on a hunt for the perfect young scientists to lead this experiment.
And he does this by going to Moscow State University,
which is not only one of the best,
but one of the most beautiful universities in the world.
And he talks to some colleagues he has there and he lays out the ideas and says
he's looking for a young scientist.
So one of the people who comes in to interview for the job is 25 year old Lewd
Mila.
The interview happened in 1958 when you talk to her today,
it seems as if it happened just yesterday.
The first thing that struck her was that belay if immediately treated her like
an equal.
So in 1958 Soviet science was very patriarchal,
but here was a vice director of an institute talking to a newly mentored
undergraduate and treating them like an equal.
And that mattered.
So believe lays out the idea we're going to test hundreds of Fox is every year
we're going to choose the calmest,
most friendly towards human foxes,
breed them.
We're going to do this generation after generation c,
do we get more calmer and calmer animals and do we begin to see floppy ears and
curly towels?
And all this stuff in the domestication syndrome.
And Luke Neil loves the idea.
She thinks it's a brilliant experiment and she also likes the idea of moving to
this new scientific oasis in the middle of Siberia.
But before she gets too excited,
belay f stops her and says,
look,
you need to know a couple of things.
First of all,
even though Lysenko is not as powerful as it used to be,
if he decided to make an example of us,
he could still throw us into prison Ludimil and knew that anyone who studied
biology knew that,
but it meant something that the lay of stopped her and said,
think about this.
And the other thing you said was,
I've run this little pilot experiment.
It's promising,
but this is an experiment in evolution,
right?
It could take 10 years before we find anything interesting.
Could take 20 years.
She remembers the lay of saying to her,
it could take your whole life.
But she was hooked.
He liked what he saw.
He offered her the position.
Six months later,
Luke,
Mila,
her husband and their two year old daughter hop on a train from Moscow to
Siberia,
which is no easy train ride to begin the full blown experiment from day one.
Would Mila will tell you that her motto comes directly from Wonderful Children's
book,
the Little Prince where the Fox tells the little prince that you become
responsible forever for what you have tamed.
So look,
Neela gets there and Blake has money and power,
but he still hasn't been able to procure a very large area to build a Fox farm.
Right.
An academic or dock where they could do the experiment he's working on that.
He's planning to do it.
But at the start there is no such place yet.
So for the first year or so live,
Neela travels around the Soviet Union to all of the,
you know too many of these Fox farms I've told you about.
All of them are owned by the government of course.
And she's trying to find the perfect place to start the experiment until they
have someplace at academic Gora doc to move it to.
And eventually she settles on one place known as the less,
no,
I fox farm,
it's about,
it's an overnight,
about 12 hour train ride from academic or a doc and leave meal.
His plan is that she'll go down there four times a year.
Some days will be for a couple of weeks.
Other visits will be for a couple of months to start the full blown experiment.
So this place,
less noise is gigantic.
It's a cash cow for the Soviet government.
At any given time there could be 10,000 foxes at less noise or being bred for
pretty firm.
And when Luke meal,
the first talked to the director there and said what she wanted to do,
he looked at her like she was nuts.
Why would anyone want to waste their time trying to build a friendlier Fox when
there's so much money to be made for the government?
Infer but led.
Mila said that [inaudible] sent me and belay his name now carried enough weight
that the director said,
fine,
test 500 foxes,
it's not going to bother me.
Go ahead and do it.
So she begins the experiment and it works like this everyday at six o'clock in
the morning she begins and she works methodically from cage to cage.
Each fox is in its own cage and she's going to score them on how friendly or not
they are towards her
and she's going to score every fox twice,
once when it's a pup,
and then once again when it's an adult and she's going to score them first as
the,
as she approaches the cage,
she'll note whether they are friendly or not towards her.
Then as she stands by their clothes cage,
then as she opens up the cage door and then as she puts something typically a
stick or her hand in a very,
very thick glove into the cage and she is going to score them on a scale of one
to four where four means relatively calm and friendly and one means relatively
not so either aggressive or running away and hiding.
So she scores everyone of around four or 500 foxes twice,
once when they're a pup,
once when they're an adult.
And then she takes the 10% that had the 10% of the males and then the 10% of the
females who had the highest aggregate score,
the friendliest of the foxes,
the top 10% of the friend,
uh,
10% friendliest foxes.
And she does this every year.
Generation after generation
initially would,
Mila describes these animals as fire breathing dragons.
They're not technically wild foxes,
but they're pretty close to it.
And most of them acted the way that you might expect foxes to act,
especially if they are in a cage.
But even after just two or three generations of selecting the calmest,
[inaudible],
friendliest animals,
there were a few and just a few foxes like Laska and Kesa.
So you're looking at Lumea law holding Laska,
which means gentle.
These animals were calm enough that Loomio could hold them in her arms.
And so she held hope that if the experiment goes on long enough,
they really will be able to find out some fundamental things about this process
of domestication.
So she goes back year after year after year,
four times a year,
and does the same thing in 1965 she comes up with this classification system.
She has what she calls class three foxes and these are animals that are either
aggressive towards or are runaway and they never make the top 10% then there are
Fox is like Laska and Kesa that are what she calls class two foxes.
These animals can be held but they don't show any emotional response towards
Lewd Mila and then there are class one foxes and these cannot only be held but
they display friendly behavior.
They wag their tails as lewd meal approaches and they wine and whimper when she
leaves.
No training,
no teaching.
This is what they do.
In 1965 class one fox is made up,
maybe 2% of the Fox is today.
They make up 80% of the foxes.
So all of that 10% that are being selected,
they're all coming from class one and class two a year later with Mila has to
expand this classification system to what she calls the class one e or the elite
domesticated foxes.
So here is a description of those foxes in lieu his own words.
In the sixth generation there appeared pups who that eagerly sought out contact
with humans not only tail wagging,
but wining,
whimpering and licking our hands in a dog like manner.
In addition,
some of those elite domesticated foxes were not only wagging their tails,
they were wagging their curly tales.
Wild foxes don't have curly tails,
but curly tells are a classic part of the Domestication Syndrome.
It's the first of the domestication syndrome traits to appear in the foxes.
Always keeping in mind that the only thing they use to determine who's going to
breed is how friendly are they are towards humans.
Whether you have a curly tail or not,
does not affect whether you're a selected to breed only behavior and yet still
here's the first of the domestication syndrome traits to appear.
So a couple of years go by.
1967 now Lysenko was gone.
He's no longer a threat.
Plus this is an important year because this is the year that the Fox farm and
academic or doc is up and operating.
This is what it looks like on a nice day in the Siberian winter.
Um,
each one of these sheds holds maybe 50 foxes and at any given time there could
be,
you know,
700 to a thousand foxes on the Fox farm.
And this was a watershed moment because it changed the dynamics of the
experiment in a couple of ways.
First of all,
it meant that Lewd Mila and a team now could work with the foxes everyday,
not just four times a year,
even if it is a couple of weeks or a couple of months every day.
The other thing that was really to look Mila was that when she was working down
in less,
knew I was too busy to come visit very often,
maybe once or twice a year.
But now he's just 20 minutes away at the institute and he can come in,
interact with the foxes anytime he wants and just as important if something
major happens.
Okay.
She can immediately get lay of over to see what's going on.
And one of those,
something important.
One of those major things with this little guy right here,
Macta or dream dream was the first of the domesticated foxes to have droopy
floppy ears.
So here's the deal about foxes and their ears in the Wild Fox
is,
do you have floppy ears still at about six weeks old and then they're your shoot
ramrod straight the way that you might imagine a fox in the wild.
Well,
at six weeks,
dreams ears were still floppy.
Two months they were still floppy.
Three months they were still floppy.
Four months they were still floppy.
Lewd,
Mila calls,
belief out there and believe,
looks at dream,
turns around and asks Lewd Mila,
what kind of wonder is this now they were seeing yet another trait in a
domestication syndrome,
not only curly towels,
but floppy ears,
all as the result of selection on behavior and behavior alone.
Ballet.
I've used to take a slide of Maca to talks
and when he would come back from these talks,
by this time,
they were not only in the Soviet Union,
but all around the world.
When he would come back,
he would tell the kneel on that.
His colleagues would come up to him after the talk and accused him of trying to
stick a picture of a dog puppy up on the screen to convince them that the Fox
experiment was working.
That so much math to look like a dog.
Okay.
So the experiment goes on year after year after year.
Right.
And one of the things that live meal in a team have always been doing along the
way is taking blood samples so that they can look for changes at the hormonal
level.
So by 1974 so about 15 generations into the experiment,
what they're finding is that they're domesticated foxes have about a 50% lower
level of stress hormones,
corticosteroids,
then wild foxes.
What's more by this point,
they have started a control line in the experiment.
So when the control line,
they test the Fox is exactly the same.
But who gets to me,
it has nothing to do with how friendly they are towards humans or aggressive.
They are towards humans.
So it's a nice control when they compare the domesticated foxes to the control.
They also find that the domesticated Fox has had about 50% lower stress hormone
levels,
and they were also beginning to see all sorts of other things appear in their
foxes.
By this time,
domesticated pups by the mid seventies open their eyes on average a day earlier
than the control foxes or wild foxes.
Domesticated pups respond to sounds two days earlier than typical foxes.
Females have a slightly extended reproductive season.
Typically Wild Fox is breed for about 10 days in late January,
early February.
Domesticated Fox's,
particularly the elite domesticated Fox's were in breeding state for about 14
days.
So a real difference,
not dramatic,
but real difference yet another one of the traits and the domestication
syndrome.
It's typical for domesticated species to have longer reproductive periods,
then their wild ancestors.
And even you also see in domesticated species,
um,
cases where wild,
the wild ancestor breeds once.
But the domestic domesticated version breeds multiple times.
Now they're beginning to see a slightly longer reproductive season.
In the domesticated females.
They were also beginning to see all sorts of strange things in their code
coloration.
Another trait in a domestication syndrome in particular,
there was this strange white star shaped pattern that was becoming more common
on the foreheads of the elite domesticated foxes.
And if any of you are horse fanatics,
you know that there are breeds of horses where you see the same thing.
And this is not uncommon,
this strange star shaped white pattern on the far ahead.
It's not uncommon and domesticated species.
Now it's in the domesticated foxes and so on.
Many,
many more changes by this time.
So at this point they decide that they're going to expand the experiment even
further.
So they've got this line,
the domesticated align where they choose the 10% that are friendliest.
They have a control line where they choose them regardless of how they behave
towards humans.
Now what they're going to do is have a third line where they choose the 10% that
are most aggressive towards humans.
Not because they're interested in aggression per se,
but because they think that having this new part of the experiment,
we'll let them understand their domesticated foxes better.
And He,
and that can happen in lots of ways.
So for example,
you could breed the foxes from the domesticated line with those from the
aggressive line and when you study their pups you can get some hints about
underlying genetic change.
But I want to focus on another reason that they did this
and that is that this whole experiment that we've been talking about,
it's an experiment in behavior and it's an experiment in genetics.
It's an experiment in behavioral genetics and anytime you do an experiment in
behavioral genetics where what you're selecting on his behavior,
you're always worried about something.
And that is,
that may be non genetic factors are influencing your results.
So over these 15 years we talked about all the things they've been finding in
the foxes in their underlying assumption has been all of these things are due to
changes at the genetic level but maybe non genetic factors are playing a role.
Classic non genetic factors might be something like pups learn whether it be
friendlier,
aggressive by watching their parents or other adults.
Another classic non genetic factor.
It would be the hormones that you're exposed to during development might
influence whether or not you turn out to be aggressive or calm.
And the only way to know whether these non genetic factors play a role is to
design an experiment.
This is often referred to as a transplant experiment,
sometimes referred to as a common garden experiment except what we're going to
be looking at.
It's a common garden experiment where the garden is the uterus of a pregnant
Fox.
So here's what Lewd Mila did.
She had five or six pairs of females.
Each pair was made up of an aggressive female and a tame domesticated female and
both females were pregnant.
And the transplant that's going to happen happens when there are about one week
pregnant,
even though no one had ever tried this in an animal,
this big Neil,
the learned the detailed surgical procedure so that she could swap developing
embryos from one uterus to another.
So here's the developing,
here's what the uterine Horn of a Fox looks like when they're pregnant and he,
and you can see that they're caring about five,
six or seven developing embryos.
What lewd meal the did was she took half of the developing embryos,
one week old from the aggressive Fox and move them over to the uterus of the
Tame Fox and took half of developing embryos from the team Fox and put them over
in the aggressive Fox.
This is the classic experiment you do to determine whether what you're seeing is
due to genetic factors and non genetic factors.
Because what you do is you wait about eight weeks in this case til the females
give birth.
Then when the pups are up and moving around,
what you do is you immediately see how they behave towards humans and you look
to see do they behave like they're genetic mother regardless of what uterus they
happen to be raised in.
If they do,
that tells you that the changes you're looking at are genetic.
If they behave like their foster mother,
then that suggests non genetic factors might be a plate.
So the Mila sets this up,
she's waiting,
but of course she has a little bit of a problem and the problem is when she
moves than one week old developing embryos from one uterus to another,
she knows who's who.
How is she going to know who is who when the females give birth?
Fortunately she thought she thought about this and recognize this problem before
she did the transplant.
The foxes can provide you the answer to that question because Fox coat color is
a very well understood genetic trait.
That means that Luke Neela could color code the parents.
So in some treatments the the domesticated female and male had like cut for a
color and the aggressive pair had dark for a color in and others vice versa.
And she then knew by the coat color of the pups who their genetic parents were.
Okay.
So she's waiting and she's waiting.
And at this point I just want to take a t tell you quickly about another group
of people involved in this experiment.
The people that live,
Mila and all the scientists referred to nicely as the workers.
So anytime you have 700 foxes on a farm,
someone's got to feed them,
change their cages,
make sure they're okay.
These are the workers and they tend to,
they tend to be poor women from local villages.
They don't understand the details of this experiment,
but they know that what's going on here is really important science.
And they often go way above the call of duty to work with,
with Mila.
And it was the workers who first discovered the females giving birth.
They ran two lewd meal,
his office with cake and wine and had a giant party to celebrate it.
So what did they find?
I'm going to show you the results from one aggressive female who gave birth to a
bunch of pups.
Okay.
The results are very similar costs all females,
but I'm going to let loose meal in her own words.
Tell you what she found.
So the male says it was fascinating.
The aggressive mother had both foster offspring and her genetic offspring.
Of course,
that is exactly the way Lou Mila set up the experiment.
Her foster team offspring were barely walking,
but if there was a human standing by,
they were already rushing to the cage doors wagging their tails and also licking
her hands in Libya.
Biola continues.
She,
the mother was punishing her foster tame offspring for such,
I love this phrase,
improper behavior.
She growled at them,
grab their necks,
threw them back into the corner of the cage,
and what did those little pups do?
But get up,
walk back over to the cage and start licking lewd meal.
His hand again,
they behaved exactly like their genetic mother,
not like their foster mother.
Okay,
so the Medulla continues.
Now she's going to look at the genetic offspring of the aggressive mother.
What did they do?
And again,
I adore the ways that she describes this.
They retain their dignity Groundling,
aggressively the same as their mother and running to their nests.
They behave like they're genetic mother.
This was common for all the pups born true aggressive females.
And it was also common to all the pups born to domesticate females.
The pups behave like their genetic mother.
Okay,
so the experiments going on and,
and,
and what's happening is happening even faster than Luke.
Mila and Blake have dreamed it would.
So at this point,
Lewd Mila goes to believe with an audacious idea.
She says there's this tiny little house on the experimental Fox farm that's 700
square feet or something.
I want to move in there with one of the elite domesticated females and live with
that individual 24 seven the way that we live with our dogs.
More importantly,
the way that our ancestors lived with pro dogs.
And I'm going to take notes on everything that happens and we can really see
just how far down the path of domestication,
the Sox's of com.
Yes,
it's only a sample size of one.
It's an anecdote but maybe it'll teach us something important.
So ballet of says I love it and Luke Mila has the perfect fox in mind.
The Fox,
his name is pushing into which means tiny ball of fluff.
And from the time that pushing go was three weeks old and walking around,
she was the friendliest of all the elite domesticated foxes in the history of
the experiment.
And Lewd Mila knew she was the one but the meal decided she's gonna wait a year
until push Inca is ready to breed at one year old and she breeds push Inca with
a elite male.
And now the idea is that she's going to move in with Pachinko right before
pushing cause ready to give birth so she can take notes,
not just on what push Inca does,
but what pups,
who from the moment they're born are interacting with humans.
The way that we interact with dog pups,
how they act.
This is the only known picture we have of pushing ballet of petting her.
This is what the experimental house looks like today.
It still stands even though this experiment is in the mid 1970 [inaudible].
But if you look inside today,
it's pure rubble.
And the reason that I'm showing you two are rubble is that the first time that I
visited in January of 2012 it was about minus 35 the snow was about up to here,
[inaudible] about up to here.
And nevertheless,
at 80 years old,
she insisted upon taking me out to the house and giving me a room by room tour
telling me this is where push Inca used to lie on the edge of my bed at night.
This is where the pups used to play ball and so on and so on.
So they moved in and on April six push Inca gave birth to her six pups,
including this little guy Prue shock,
which is the male version of tiny ball of fluff.
And she took notes on everything that they did.
And so this was April and they had been living together for about three months.
So it's now July.
Now.
This picture comes from when I was there in the winter,
but in the summer,
in July,
it's really hot in Siberia.
You can get to be 90 degrees at night.
And so what [inaudible] would do every evening is there on the other side of
this house,
there's a little bench.
And she would sit out there reading a book and like you might with your dog poo,
Shingo would be lying by your side and we'd be able to it.
We'd be reading and petting push income.
And every evening around 7:00 PM or so,
there was a guard that would come around the Fox farm just to make sure
everything was okay.
And they had hired a new guard that nobody knew.
And this guard on the night of July 15th was approaching with Mila and push
Shanka and it sort of brisk way that maybe you might interpret as slightly
aggressive.
And Little Mila looked down at push Inca and she could not believe what was
happening.
Push Inca had bolted up,
charged towards the nightwatch person and began barking at them exactly the way
that a guard dog wood and exactly like no Fox and the history of the experiment
had ever barked
and would Neil,
his first thought was pushing because protecting me.
But then she stopped and said,
wait a minute,
I know better than most how dangerous it is to fall into that trap to think that
animals are behaving the way we would in that situation.
But then something else happened,
which was that Lumelleau low went over to the watch person and began talking to
them in a very calm,
serene way.
And when push,
because saw that she stopped barking,
walked back over to the bench,
lay down and weighting weighted for Lewd Mila to come back and start reading.
Is it possible push Inca wasn't protecting,
would Mila?
Of course it's possible.
But would Mila wanted to know with just how down far down the path of
domestication these animals had come in?
Push Inca told her that.
And because you are become responsible forever for what you have teamed.
Lewd.
Mila will tell you from that night forward,
she knew she would never leave the experiment and she never has.
So let me just take five more minutes to quickly run you through some of the
other incredible things that have gone on in this experiment.
I mentioned before that in the 70s the reproductive season of the leaf
domesticated animals had was slightly longer and other traits in the
domestication syndrome in the early eighties something remarkable happened in
about 84
a handful,
maybe four or five of the elite domesticated foxes were ready to breed twice in
a year.
Not only in the typical January,
February time,
but a second time in September.
Absolutely unheard of ever in foxes,
but typical for domesticated animals,
Lewd Neil,
a bread,
those handful of a lead females with a handful of elite males who would breed
with them.
They produced a second clutch of pups.
Think about how radical the change has to be a reproductive system to be able to
go from breeding just once a year to twice a year,
all as the result of selection on behavior and only behavior.
By the eighties and nineties Luke Mila was working with people who have very
sophisticated equipment that allowed her to measure the faces and bodies of the
atom,
of her,
of her domesticated foxes.
And what she found was a couple of things.
First of all,
the domesticated foxes have a rounder,
shorter,
more doglike stout.
If you think of a fox in the wild,
you think of this long pronounced now domesticated foxes more doglike,
round short.
Another thing you might think of a domesticated foxes.
Another thing you might think of of Wild Fox is,
is they have these grass Cya Lynn's that they're running around on the
domesticated foxes are chunkier and lower to the ground than wild foxes are.
So as the experiment progresses and we get into the era of molecular genetics,
they begin looking at these questions.
And what happened was there was a geneticist by the name of Anna Kournikova,
a Russian geneticists who had worked with dogs.
And she approached me,
Mila,
because now that the tools for studying genetics and dogs are easily adaptable
to foxes,
and she says,
do you want to do some work trying to understand the underlying molecular
genetic changes and what on a learned,
which is what everybody learns when they work with leukemia,
which is that if she thinks that you can help her better understand her
domesticated Fox is she will not only work with you,
she will work with you in a way that will make your head spin.
And before she knew it,
Ana had hundreds of blood samples.
It allowed them to start doing an analysis of the underlying molecular genetic
changes that have occurred in their foxes.
And they've done this in many,
many different ways.
I'm just going to show you one.
Okay.
An early study.
So one of the first questions they asked was this.
There were all these changes that have happened with a domesticated Fox is not
only they're calmer,
but all the behave,
all the morphological changes.
We talked about the floppy ears,
the cro hotels and so on.
The first question was,
and a molecular genetic level,
are the genetic changes associated with that?
Are they kind of spread all over the genome of the foxes or are they localized
in sort of hotspots of genetic change associated with the domestication?
What they found was many,
not all,
but many of the changes in their domesticated foxes could be localized to one
chromosome.
Fox chromosome number 12 that sort of interesting,
right?
It's not spread all over the genome.
It's in a hotspot or in one of a couple of hot spots.
More interesting was that at the same time they were asking that question.
A group of people were asking the same exact question and dogs,
so dogs have more chromosomes than foxes,
but Fox chromosome number 12 is essentially spread across bits of it are spread
across three dog chromosomes.
For anyone who is a biologist.
These are homologous chromosomes,
but basically Fox chromosomes 12 is divided up into bits of it on to three dog
chromosomes.
Lo and behold,
one of those three dog chromosomes again,
is a hotspot for domestication changes associated with domestication.
So even deep down at the molecular genetic level,
it looks like they're mimicking the process that happened with wills to dogs.
Okay,
last gamble.
I'm going to tell you about one trait that they have only found in the last 15
years,
and this may be my favorite of all the traits that the domesticated foxes have,
but before I tell you what it is,
when I tell you why it's my favorite,
it's a couple of reasons.
First of all,
this trait did not appear until about 15 years ago,
so that means the experiment was going on 45 years before this trade emerge,
making it the poster child for why long term experiments are important.
If any one of us had worked 30 years on a given biological system,
we would sit back and start getting lifetime achievement awards and you would
not have worked nearly long enough.
In a system for something like this.
The second reason I love this trait is it's hard to imagine a more perfect trait
for a domesticated pet like species to have than this.
So here's the story.
In about two s the early two thousands woman by the name is fit Lana Gogal Lova
approach leave me alone and Svetlana Studies,
animal communication.
And she said,
I want to come there and I just,
I want to study the,
the sounds that you're fox is make and I want to study it in the domesticated
Fox is to control foxes and the aggressive foxes.
See what we might find lewd.
Mila said,
great,
honest,
Svetlana started coming year after year,
ended up with 2000 hours of tapes of the sounds,
these Fox Smith and what she found was across all the foxes domesticated control
and,
and and aggressive.
There are about eight different unique sounds they make.
Most of those sounds are made by foxes in all the groups domesticated,
control and aggressive.
But there were two,
and I'm going to focus on one here that is only,
that are only made by the domesticated foxes.
And the one that we're going to hear in a second.
This is only made by domesticated Fox.
It's made by almost all of them,
and it's made from the their time,
from the time that they start walking around.
And this is what it sounds like,
right?
There is no nonhuman sound that's closer to human laughter then that sound,
if you put it on a spectrogram and look at it and compare it to him and
laughter,
there's no use,
there's no sound.
It's closer to human laughter and it's,
it's almost too perfect,
right?
I mean,
now you have an animal that is not only incredibly friendly and incredibly cute,
but you have an animal that's going to laugh with you when you're laughing and
it's going to laugh with you when you're angry and it's going to laugh with you
when you're crying cause it doesn't care about any of that.
But nonetheless,
it's making this perfect sound right?
It's just what you'd want to have in a domesticated species.
Okay.
So if you talk to Mila 60 years after she began and continues to work on this
experiment and you ask her about our hopes and the dreams for the future,
what you'll get is you'll get a six hour answer,
but I'll give you the quick version.
The first thing she'll tell you is,
I hope it's possible to register them as a new pet species.
So technically they are considered an exotic species.
There are in fact a couple of dozen in people's houses across the United States
in Europe,
but because they're in and they're very expensive and all the money goes to the
experiment,
but because they were an exotic species,
the rules about whether you can have one of these very,
not just from country to country and from state to state,
but from city to city in subdivision to subdivision.
Now there is an international panel that can,
um,
assess whether an animal,
it should be considered a house pet and they're working to get that
classification.
Once they do,
then the Fox is,
could go into any houses anywhere.
And what Lunula envisions is they have plenty of foxes to keep the experiment
going and also to put a few hundred into people's houses every year.
The other thing that Luke,
Mila,
we'll tell you about her hopes is one day I'll be gone,
but I want my foxes and the experiment to live forever.
I do.
I hope you do and I appreciate you guys taking your lunch to hear this talk.
Thanks very much.
Okay.
In the anthropology classes,
you hear about this like nonstop,
so I'm curious.
Oh really?
You hear about this experiment?
Oh yeah.
Oh good.
That's good to know.
That's part of the curriculum.
I'm wondering when you first heard about it all.
Well,
you know,
because my own degree,
an evolutionary biology,
I don't remember exactly when,
but it must have been in one of my graduate classes because it is a very famous
experiment.
Um,
I got involved in it.
you know,
uh,
seriously about 10 years ago when I was looking for a,
for a new history of science project,
um,
I had done some work on Russian evolutionary biology.
So I knew not only about some of the basics things they found.
See the thing is a lot of people know a little bit about this experiment because
95% of it is published in Russian.
So people know about floppy ears and stuff,
but not a lot.
So I knew a little bit about the science and I thought,
I know this is important science,
but I also had a sense that Lysenko was involved.
I had a sense that there were some really interesting human animal bonding
stories and all of that.
So I approached with Neil about it and,
and,
and she was keen on,
on doing something.
So I'd say 10 years ago and it's been great.
I mean,
we've meal and that whole group in Novosibirsk have become like family.
um,
and she,
you know,
I just emailed with her the other day and she's,
she's doing four lane and she's still leading the experiment.
Yeah,
sure.
Thanks for the talk.
The foxes are adorable.
Um,
I'm curious if they try to control for researcher's bias,
Mila favor animals that have the domestication.
Yup.
It's a great question.
Right?
And so,
um,
this is an inherent problem in this kind of experiment where you're going to
gauge behavior.
So I think that over the course of the experiment,
they've gotten much better and tighter about this.
Initially.
Like when I talked about that place less new I,
it was really allude Mila and Lewd Mila alone.
But once the experiment moved in 1967 to the experimental farm and there was a
whole team of people,
they began to do other things that really controlled as much as possible for
what you're talking about.
Okay.
So first of all,
the key thing they do is they've adopted techniques that come from psychology
because psychologists have this problem all the time.
You're measuring behavior and how do you know you're only using the,
what you think you are maybe are being affected by other things.
The classic way to do this is to have multiple different people independently
assess whatever is being looked at.
And then look for tight correlations across people in terms of who says the
animals friendly and who isn't.
And that's what they do.
Now the other thing that they do is that there's many,
many components of behavior that they're looking for,
not just the four things that Lewd Mila talked about early on.
That's still the core of it is they're still looking for attributes of
friendliness towards humans,
but they sub divided that into dozens of different things.
So that plus the multiple observers is the classic way to handle this problem.
And they do the best they can with it.
Yeah.
Just a question.
Okay.
Same question.
First of all,
thanks for the talk yet.
I was wondering in your words,
you said that this happened sort of like in the blink of an eye on an
evolutionary scale,
cause that's something inherent to foxes are like how quickly they reproduce or
to some larger classification of animals.
And like if you,
if you selected something from like a totally different,
not related at all to foxes are wolves,
what would happen?
Yeah,
it's a great question.
Um,
and,
um,
we,
we know the answer to some extent because on the other side of the farm where
the Fox is,
are,
are hundreds and hundreds of mink.
And for the last 40 years,
another person has been running the exact same protocol on mink and finding very
parallel results.
So there's smaller animals,
so,
so the,
the,
they're not quite as dramatic and sexy is what happens in the factors.
But if you choose on behavior and behavior alone,
and they'd done that both domesticated and aggressive,
like with the foxes,
you not only get behavioral changes,
but you get changes in code,
coloration,
hormone levels,
juvenile eyes,
facial patterns,
all of that same sort of stuff.
I will tell you
that as scary as the aggressive,
the foxes that have been bred for aggression are the foxes that the,
the minks that have been bred for aggression.
I,
I still have nightmares walking by those cages.
I mean,
they're,
they're demonic.
But,
um,
and there's a third experiment that started with their group but then migrated
to one of the Max Planck institutes in Germany where they're doing essentially
the exact same thing in rats.
And again,
smaller animals,
so not as dramatic but seem basic results,
select on behavior you get,
not just changes in the behavior but the morphological at atomical hormonal
change
like uh,
the number of generations.
Was it sort of like a similar timeline?
Yeah,
I mean,
so the mink to breed once a year,
uh,
and I,
I think they are beginning to see serious changes within a couple of dozen
generations,
like the foxes.
Now you have to remember also that this is,
I mean it,
it's hard to say anything about sort of the,
um,
the absolute amount of time and how important that is in the domestication
process in the wild only because this is really super intense selection.
You know,
you're just choosing the top 10%,
you know,
in evolutionary history,
our ancestors would not have been doing that kind of thing.
And initially it would have been non con unconscious selection,
you know,
just sort of the ones that can closest we're the ones that were friendliest and
so on.
And then when they started doing consciously,
it would not have been to the intensity that we're talking about here.
Sure.
So one thing that you kept bringing up in this presentation is stop the specific
domesticated behaviors of foxes,
uh,
acquire our dog like behaviors.
And I know that there is some relationship,
I'm not sure how close it is,
but are there differences between the two that's still persist in?
Is there,
how close are they really after domestication in this form?
Well,
I guess I can answer that in a couple of different levels.
First there they're both canines,
right?
So they haven't ever loot.
They have a shared evolutionary history,
but they,
their,
their most recent common ancestor was on the order of 12 million years ago.
But they're,
but they're all canines.
I use the language of their behavior is very dog,
like as a,
as a way to sort of put it in context,
meaning they lick hands,
they wag towels and so on.
Um,
in that sense they are very doglike,
but um,
in many,
many other ways,
they are not.
So they are not animals that are inherently gregarious.
They don't necessarily,
you know,
they're,
they're not animals that like to live in groups.
There are many,
many differences between the domesticated foxes and dogs,
but there are a tremendous number of similarities that seem to be due to
choosing for this,
this prosocial behavior.
I mean,
um,
you know,
at the genetic level,
you,
uh,
although the underlying changes like we talked about have been similar that,
you know,
you couldn't breed them or anything like that.
Right?
Yeah.
I guess I don't want to hold up,
but I would have also asked how far away are we from speciation?
Yeah,
that's a good question.
And the answer is very far.
I think there's no,
so the,
the,
the aggressive foxes and the domesticated foxes can breed perfectly well.
They do it all the time to understand the underlying genetics.
They've never attempted anything with Wild Fox is because they're terrified of
introducing rabies and all this sort of thing.
But there's no reason in the world to think that they wouldn't read perfectly
well with Wild Fox is so,
so,
so far.
Um,
there's not reproductive barriers,
but again,
this is 60 years,
which is nothing.
If they ran the experiment for another 500 years,
would there be differences?
Maybe even that's a small amount of evolutionary time,
but,
but you know,
we don't know.
Right.
Thank you.
You're welcome.
Hi.
Um,
I was wondering what the lifespan of the foxes are and if it changed when they
were domesticated.
Another good question.
So believe it or not,
we don't know a tremendous amount about the lifespan of wild foxes.
Um,
people estimated at maybe,
you know,
on average two or three years,
uh,
the,
all the foxes on the Fox farm can live six,
seven years now.
But in terms of differences,
there are no differences between the domesticated animals and the,
uh,
the domesticated line,
the aggressive line and control.
And so one of the changes has not been longer lifespan.
They have slightly more offspring,
but,
but not longer lifespan per se.
Yes.
Hi.
Um,
of course this experiments has never run for,
uh,
humans.
Oh,
I'm glad you're going to ask what you're going to ask.
Go ahead.
I mean,
once you dedicate your whole life,
I'm sure she had some great observations on humans.
I wonder if she ever exchange any stories with you or any observations.
So we,
we,
we do
about this a little bit in the book I went,
so here's the short version.
Um,
in the late seventies,
belaying her mentor and the person who basically,
you know,
was her goto person on this,
on this experiment,
Belay IV hypothesize that human evolution was an example of self domestication.
And the self domestication idea is this
instead of some external force choosing the animals that are friendliest or
comest in self domestication that happens by mate choice.
So the idea was in evolutionary history,
both males and females would have been more likely to choose calmer,
more cooperative mates,
right?
For all sorts of reasons.
First of all,
interpersonal aggression would be minimized and also things that require
cooperation would have been maximized.
And the argument then is that by doing that,
by selecting the calmest,
friendliest animal,
uh,
mates,
you are in fact mimicking the process of domestication.
It's just self domestication.
This was an idea that ballet I've had in the late seventies didn't really do a
lot with it.
Just in the last three months.
Richard Wrangham,
a colleague of mine at Harvard has an entire book out on human self
domestication and now there's evidence from all different fields to suggest that
we may very well be the product of domestic self domestication.
And the evidence comes in lots of different forms,
one of which is that if you compare,
if you compare it to wrap up please.
I got it.
Okay.
I'm ready to stop anytime you guys are.
I use a,
you have to tell me when to stop.
Um,
uh,
um,
so one of the forums is that if you compare us to our closest living relatives,
meaning chimpanzees,
we tend to show traits that are more in the domestication syndrome than
chimpanzees do,
right?
We show we have longer reproductive periods,
we have lower stress hormone levels,
we have many juvenile ISED feature is compared to chimpanzees there.
And there are many other forms of evidence that to that we have self
domesticated ourselves.
Um,
I would suggest if you're interested,
the book Richard's book is called the goodness paradox,
and it just came out.
It's getting a lot of attention on,
you can easily find it on Amazon when you search for my book.
So there you go.
Thank you very much.